I was raised by a single mom lately I've
been thinking about how I'll move out
one day and I get so upset I love her
more than anything and I can't imagine
leaving her all alone I was raised by a
single mom and four sisters they never
stressed about teaching me to be a real
man but they did value me being a good
person and you know what I'm proud of
the man I am my dad is a single parent
mom left us when I was a baby but you
know what I really am fortunate my dad
is so inspiring he's tough and caring
he's taught me what it truly means to be
an amazing parent grew up with a single
mom she teaches us to cook and work on
cars we call her Wonder Woman and she
loves it my dad is the best part of my
life alone he's raising my baby sister
and I all while serving 10 plus years in
the Navy he's just the best my dad has
had a hard life
and is still the kindest man I know one
day soon I have to provide him with a
life he deserves it is my biggest goal
my mom is a single parent if we would
sir care of us kids while working and
going to college I can't think of a
better example of a hero than her
you